O ne o
[Müzik]
abone ol
Evet
hepinize Saygılar sunuyoruz benim gibi
hem zihinsel hem fiziksel fotoğraf
bilgisi olan birileri bu halının içinde
18 dakika
bilmiyoruz Çünkü 62 yaşında bir
öğretmenin emekli öğretmenim ve zaman
zaman diyorum ki Eğer şimdi okulda
olsaydı Muhtemelen bana ilaç vermek
isteyecekler de ama bulunuyor bir
aktivite gidebiliyor bu cam
çocukluğundan al getirdi Ben de Bugün
sizlerle buluşmam da 41 yıl da bitirmiş
Bir Eğitimci olarak karşınızdayım
ödemekte oldu Ama anladım ki böyle bir
emeklilik yok
seviyorsanız ve hayata farkındaysanız
Eğer Çok sağ ol hocam çocukluğu dedi Ben
de size 41 yıllık Çalışma Hayatında
istiyorum
2980 yılında Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı'nda
İngilizce olarak görmeye başladım
öğretmenliği bilerek ve isteyerek seçtim
Hatta ben o yaşında Öğretmen olmak
istediğinde bir akıllı tahtalar Yok
bildiğimiz
anlatılırdı ve kendimi şöyle kadar dım
hazırlanırken ödevlerini yaparken o
zaman da kapılar yağlıboya buldu beyaz
yağlıboya Hatta bir boya yapıldı döner
kokusu çıkmazdı hep pembe Işıl'ın vardı
o da sanki birileri varmış gibi kapının
arkasında yazarak ders anlattığı
bahsediyorum bu
söylüyorum bilerek ve isteyerek öğretmen
oldum ben göreve başladığı mıdır
sorumlusu gitar Amerika bölgesi
eğitimlerine bakıyorum
991 yılında oyunlarda yaptığım bir
çalışma Milli Eğitim Bakanı kim
[Müzik]
Evet
şimdi oğlum ve şimdi birlikte biz Şifa
gittik ya 91/1 lütfen gençlere
söylüyorum gözünüzü kapatın hiç cep
telefonu yok bilgisayarı görmemiştim ve
3 aktarma ile Amerika'yı başa bilmişlik
neredeyse bir daha fazla sürmüştü Böyle
Olduğunu hayal ettiğiniz istiyorum ben
gittim oturdum göreve başladım Biraz
daha bir şeyler önce kısaldım ama o
yüzden işte belki bir santimden yapıp
bir odaya oturdular diye bilgisayar var
bilgisayarın altındaki ediyorsunuz ama
işte işlemci ve neredeyse benim yanım
kadar bu sürebiliriz odaya girdiğinde
benim diğer gördüğünü güzelmiş ya
[Müzik]
bu sonra yan tarafları Dışişleri
Bakanlığı var başka sonuçlar koşunuz
mavi var bizde milleti Bakanlığı olarak
bitişleri bir dairede oturuyoruz
yaklaşık 34 katlı bir daha cadde
üzerinde şurada
başvuru 31
[Müzik]
O
çok fazla ve Türkiye'de hale geldik
yağmurdan hiç Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı
bütçesi 70
Ne sordum ne yapıyor şimdi kimle
gideceksin dahaki maçı kalacaksınız
fakat mahkeme Tabii öğlen filmlerdeki
gibi değil yani bir odada iki tane
hakim var ve bizi mahkemelere bakarlar
yönetimin avukatı var hafif bir şeyler
söylüyor şu hiçbir şey anlamadım
öğretmeni hiçbir şey mi
bu
etmelisiniz hiçbir şey olmuş o gün
anladım ki böyle başlamış bir şey
sizlerle bu öğrenme olduğunu anlatacağım
Aslında ben 41 çalışırken başka bir
öğrenci olduğu yaptım paylaşmak
istiyorum inceliğinde tavuk suyu onu da
Sen bir şey söylemedin Ateş
söyleyebildiği şuydu dediler olmuştu
Erzincan'da deprem olmuştu dedim ki
Türkiye değersin kendi krema olduğu o
yüzden iki bazı zorlukları var ve
kirada gelmekte zorluklar hakim dedi ki
yani başka bir yerden
cevap verdim ve Ben döndüm hemen
bakanlıkları düşünüyorum başladım Her
benim için çok üzüldüm ya
bu
video üç o Okey kuralları içerisinde
birçok insan olarak Ülkemizi temsil eden
biri olarak doğru
duygusal zeka o
iyi
bir iş yapmada sonra
en son fıstığı da gidebilir Eğitim
Bakanlığı'nda sizlerin diyemeyeceğim ama
burada bu şimdi Bu soğukluğun gece
kitaplarını
programları bir Partisi'nde görev
almışım
olduk ve o
bak Buda benim için yeterli olacağını
eğitim giydim ama şimdi Türkiye'nin
Avrupa Birliği yolculuğunda uç başlıklı
neler yapabileceğini ve renk olarak
götürmek hocam
programın tanıtılması konusunda çok
istediğim benim bütün bu da
[Müzik]
mı başka ülkelerin başka kültürleri
çalışmalarıyla ortak iş yapma
becerisinin Herkes kendi ülkemize Fatih
koruyarak nasıl yapılacağını öğrettim
Bu bir konuda sizin hürmet isterken
başka birini bunu sorgulayarak baktığını
gördüm algılar farklı Çünkü intercooler
farklı yara bir konuyu değerlendirirken
varmak istediğimiz sonuçta herkesin
kullandığı değil ya da gelmiş suç mu
[Müzik]
da
mutlaka almamız gerekiyor Bugün
servisleri ama başka şeyler de öğretti
öyleyim bir güzel gelemezsin da hangi
konuda olursa
Olumlu ya da olumsuz bir sonuç almadan
kalkacağım
Bu bir durması diyelim Evet derken Hayır
hayır derken TRT1 olduğunu için çok
önemli bir öğretmen var
sonrasında 2006 yılında emekli olup
tüketimden oldu
Of of
bir şey arkadaşım
bütün bu öğrenmelerinde onlara ne kadar
daha uzun uzun var bir şekilde anne ve
babalara lütfen çocuklarınıza gelecek
hazırlamayı onları geleceği hazırladık
bilmediğimiz bir gelenek açacağım amca
bilmediğimiz o geleceğe neler yapmanız
gerektiği konusunda çocuklarımızın
gereği ya da çocuklar sizi dinlemezler
onlar sizlerle ne kadar doğru mu
[Müzik]
eve gitmeyi değil
o öncülerin sihirle unutulmayan efsane
olarak almak için çaba gösterir demeyi
onların öğrenme yolculuğundaki
arkadaşların dediği hiç faaliyetleri
ve yöneticilerin okulda asıl işlerini da
işler değil bütün ekiplerinin o
öğrenmeye uzunluğunda biberlik olduğunu
söyle hiç fark etmedim ve bütün
uluslararası olması gerektiğini hep
Çünkü görüyorsunuz ve sen politik
uyanmak ne demek Bu da
o lise sağlık sınırlar içinde hiçbir şey
ifade etmiyor bütün süreçteki bana Neyi
öğretti akademik Zeka mı çok yaşayacağız
ve sonrasında beğen temizliğinde 2021'de
oldum
Burak'ın bölgelerinde bunda yaz
olduğu için toplum kuruluşu senin
çocuğun birlikte ne yapabiliriz
dediklerinde deneyiminden kaynaklı
olarak Dedim ki şu anda yerde gelmedi
koşacaksınız Onların ihtiyaçlarını temin
edeceksiniz ama sonrasında herkes
çekilecek Anneler ve çocuklar lazım
olacak var biliyorum deli bir soru hiç
kimse konuşacağım eğer benden bir şey
istiyorsanız ben onu çok Sürdürülebilir
yapmak istiyorum dedim dediler omuz ve
özellikle
çocuklar için iklim değişikliği nedir
diye bir
program hazırladım ve o bu itibariyle
yalan köyleri gezerek bir değişiklik yok
Selam bugün klasik küresel bütün
sorunlar yoksullukla mücadele artık
benim yapmam gereken bir işi verme
postermania Üniversitesi'nin
profesörüdür an pastanesinden ölümüne
çok hazırlan kaldığımı doktorundan
öğrendiğinde bir konuşma yapar bir şey
kendi Hayallerimi gerçekleştirdim bundan
sonra Başkalarının hayallerini
gerçekleştirmek istiyorum der ki
Allah
bütün yaptıklarını 7 kelime üzere Bu bir
farkındalık
ama
her şey iki eski yaptık işte etmek güç
Çelik olmak zihinsel duygusal çektik
Hemen de anda Adam 3
bu başlık evsel hem zihinsel ve aşık
olmak istiyor ne
olduğunu gördük
Yılmaz ve dayanılmaz Hayat balık hiç
açma
mücadele eden farklı bir
ve sonrasında
Sürdürülebilir bir insanı da sürdürdü
her yaş yapıyorsa o işi sürekli
Sürdürülebilir olması en önemli şey
abone ol
bu Eğer kişi yok yapıyorsunuz gönüllü
olarak o işleri isteklisi ve Ne yapalım
ve o yaptığımız şey değerlendireceği o
yaptığımız için etkileyen çok yüksek
oluyor o yaptığımız iş başı hiç bir
şeyler etkileniyor ve çok sapasağlam
duruyor Bu nedenle kendine buketleri
artık vazgeçilmez kelimelerini aldım ve
hayatımı bu kelimeler üzerinde
kullanabiliriz
kolay değil 41
istedim ki benim 41 yıllık Çalışma
Hayatında ben ne arar bir hiç Biz
kendini öğrenme tamamlandı diye görmedim
Emekli olduğum zaman farklı sıfatlarla
beğen
en uzun günler eğitim Emek verdiğim için
tahmin edebileceğiniz gibi işte eğitimde
uzman bu hayat hiçbirini kabul etmedim
işlemi buradada profilinde göreceksiniz
Ben aslında sıra hem hayatım çıkayım hep
bir eğitim ve ustalık tehlikeli
öğrenmeyi Dur dur Hem deforme ediyor
aslında şu anda öğrenmeyi bıraktığımız
Bugün
hiç yaşamak istemiyorum ya
[Müzik]
[Alkış]